it is time for a new twist on the fast
casual latin dining experience and we're
going to learn how to
do it it is going to be done here and
here to tell us more
is fred de la torre founder of gabby's
gorditas welcome to the kitchen
thank you for having us i'm glad to be
here well tell us a little bit
about this experience at gabby's
gorditas it is new to the valley and the
southwest part of town and
why did you decide to open it well you
know i i think looking at
the way we eat as a culture has had an
effect
health-wise towards us yeah and we
refuse to
eat healthy and we're stubborn with
flavor we feel that
cooking with heavy stuff and and that's
the only way to cook so when i started
this
i took an approach of you know hitting
it with what's healthy
and light and good i love this because
my mom makes mexican food and you're
right they do
lard and they do lots of fat and all
that so let's find out how can we make a
gordita
with quality ingredients like you have
at gabby's gourd well it's very simple
right
i mean we do everything in-house so we
do the dough
okay and you know we put a little just a
little
little flour and we'll press it almost
like
if you were making corn tortillas i love
these these little tortilla makers these
are
it's very staple yes it is so you get
these very simple
okay and then you get in a pan and again
these are things that you can
just do really quick at home it's cool
it's it's very
light it's not heavy is this typical
like um
tortilla dough or is this different for
the gourd it's it's a little bit
like the flour it is like a tortilla
it's a flour tortilla
it's just the way that we do it it airs
it out a little bit more and it gets it
a little
thicker security so we're we're putting
it on the heat now is this going to help
it rise
yes usually if you had a really like a
flat top it works really well like a
skillet you might have those
you know the old school you do your
pancakes in yeah that's the way you can
do it you can just do it really quick
okay like i said it doesn't take much
you know you just look get a nice little
brownness to it
very easy and again you can mix it up
with whatever you want we used
you know ingredients that had no gmos
that have no steroids no antibiotics
organic
organic ingredients so again what is
this here this is
it's think of it as uh
chicken cacciatore oh it smells
delicious okay so we've got that and
then what's over on this and then we
have rajas which are poblano chee
poblano peppers roasted and then we put
some oaxacan cheese
and little vegetables on there and again
vegetarian it's good
add a little bit of cream it looks like
a little cotija here
cabbage cabbage pickled cabbage pickled
onions and a spanish jardner okay let's
put one together here do it okay
we got the all right so we got it nice
and fluffy
and then this is the technique right
okay you just got to
all right this is good and gabby's
gorditas where are you located
blue diamond and decatur okay if you
want to check them out
quality ingredients authentic let's go
chicken i'm going for it my
producers say in 30 seconds oh i'm
eating this so you're not going to
get it okay we put a little cabbage on
there
we did a little acidic this is authentic
the smells i'm taken back to my mom's
kitchen this is fantastic
and right here it's very very easy a
little bit of sauce on there
is that avocado yes avocado cream oh my
gosh all right
it's worth it
oh my gosh thank you i'm going home
stacey
over to you make me one moment i want
one they look so good
there's more last